make your own industry  recreate movies  don't pay attention to industry do your  own thing  i mean  put it this way  you want the work to be seen  but it doesn't have to be the odeon  you know  no more that's all different that's all  god's another ancient world  that type of film or not even the type  of film the  the the communal experience is always  important you can make a film on a  camera the size of that doorknob and  still show it to 600 people in an  audience it's still a great communal  experience you know it doesn't  necessarily mean it has to cost  over 100 million  pounds you know it's all new you just  break it open break open the form don't  just uh  you younger ones you make a new art  take what's available push it  you know  because it's going to go there you could  do anything